voters in western Pennsylvania are
headed to the polls today for a closely
watched special election it's to fill
the House seat vacated by Republican Tim
Murphy president Trump won the 18th
district by almost 20 percentage points
in 2016 but a new mammoth University
Monmouth pardon me University poll on
today's election shows Democrat Connor
Lam leading Republican Rick ciccone by 6
points from Nancy Cordes he says at a
polling place in Mount Lebanon near
Pittsburgh Nancy good morning good
morning and that Democrat Connor Lam is
set to vote here in Mount Lebanon within
the hour and the reason that the entire
political world is focused on his race
is because of what they think it might
portend for November's midterm elections
how has a Democrat been able to get so
close in what should be Trump country
and that's why the Trump family has gone
all-in Republican Rick Ciccone spent his
final campaign day with Donald Trump jr.
during a candy factory in Canonsburg
here's 2500 pounds of chocolate the
state lawmaker has also scored not one
Rick ciccone but two visits from
President Trump vote for rick Ciccone
and we can leave right now
and yet polls show Democrat Connor lamb
a former Marine and federal prosecutor
has closed the gap thanks to some
high-powered help of his own the 47th
vice president of the United States Joe
Biden and a focus on pensions Medicaid
and Medicare people have paid into these
programs it has forced national
Republicans to sink 10 million dollars
into what should be an easy race Connor
is a Pelosi liberal and it may have
prompted President Trump to make that
surprise announcement about steel
tariffs and a lot of steel mills are now
opening up Ciccone is hoping the move
revs up his base like to see this still
come back yeah how big of a difference
do you think this turbine is I think
it's good for my area city even a
lifelong residents like Don Nixon say
they don't know which way today's vote
will go it's interesting to me how tight
has been what's happened to president
Trump's popularity here in the past year
you either really like him a lot or you
can't stand him in what may have been a
last-ditch attempt to fire up
conservative Ciccone said in his final
rally yesterday that some Democrats here
hate God and hate this country
Republicans in Washington who are
worried about the outcome have already
begun doing some damage control saying
if Ciccone loses it's because he himself
was a lackluster candidate Nora will be
watching Nancy thank you so much